2020 has not been much to rave about
these days but honey you are on quite
the high
you've got to hit series emily in paris
so you've come to teach the french some
american tricks
has anyone noticed this is a very
dysfunctional workplace
i think you're the one bringing the
drummer i'm so happy he's insane
oh my god i'm so excited you know
anything about it can you give us
anything before you like i don't
know anything yet we're all having those
conversations but i know that we all
want to get back there
as soon as possible right the wardrobe
the hunks i just need more
fun and you just got engaged so how are
you feeling about all your surprises
you got to do it you know i know it's
always like it's like what
sorry what
no i'm so excited it's been a really
interesting time
to self-reflect and to think on
prioritizing and kind of
just thinking about so much stuff while
we've been at home and and to be able to
bring
two projects to people right now through
netflix
globally is a huge gift and to make
people laugh and smile with emily in
paris
god knows that's what we all need to do
more of right now and then with mank i
feel like there's this
like nostalgia for the world that once
was that we're already all
feeling so there's that way to connect
with people through that
and it's so funny when we got engaged so
many friends and family were like
thank you i'm like why like thank you
for giving us something to look forward
to i was like oh yeah we totally did it
for you guys
right so awesome but it has been
yeah i'm i'm very grateful i'm grateful
for a lot of things right now as you
should be young lady are you having fun
with all the wedding planning is charlie
any good at planning things for them
we're we're having fun it's like this is
like a fun
part you get to think about all those
things you've
you know as a young girl thinking like
oh what do i want one day it's like now
you get to
actually play and have conversations
about it i hope i see a little redford
in the wedding because he's just
he's like sleeping right now i don't
know where he is i know mine is too he's
right behind me but
let's talk about make don't flatulence
you're not writing an opera
but i am writing an opera
how familiar were you with these main
players and one man in particular that
was behind the scenes of one of the
films that has been
the greatest of our time before reading
the script i grew up loving old
hollywood
being immersed in um life in l.a
at a young age you know you'd see the
hollywood sign and it's like it's just
magical and i used to love watching
black and white movies and loving old
hollywood movie stars i even went to
hearst castle with my mom when i was
younger so i
really felt already very attached to the
subject matter and then when i read the
script
i had no idea of the making of i did not
know who herman mankowitz was i knew
mary and davies william purse
to be mayor i didn't know that arita
alexander existed that she was a real
person
so it was really fun to actually feel
like i knew the world because i had also
done
a movie and a tv show that dealt with a
similar period in hollywood but then to
also go oh my god i had no idea of this
other
side to it so i i found it really fun to
do research
and to kind of envelop myself in this
world in a whole new way
just so fascinating so glamorous and yet
so heartbreaking
at the same time and certain elements of
the film
you know everyone wanted mate to step
away from creating citizen kane from
writing it because it was so
controversial has there ever been a time
in your career
when your team was like well you
shouldn't do this project and you said
you know what
i've got to i want to and everything
turned out just fine
after you did do the project it was less
my team
and i think just people close to me in
my life that
were concerned or worried
in the pursuing uh for myself of doing
to the bone
because it's a movie based you know
about eating disorders and mental health
and and that being something i had been
open about having gone through myself
that's not breakfast
neither is coffee you do a lot of
sit-ups
i'm not going to treat you if you aren't
interested in living i completely
respected and understood why people
would say maybe this isn't a great idea
for you but i just knew it was something
i had to do i had to tell this story i
had to work with marty knox and i
i had to be the voice that got to tell
ellen's story because of my experiences
and the healing process of it and i just
knew that playing this character would
allow me to heal in a new way and to
tell the story was so important
it's something that globally no matter
who you are what age you are
you can relate to or have empathy for in
a greater way
i knew it was something much bigger than
myself and that i had to do it and it's
one of my most
treasured proud experiences and and
project
because of the outreach that it's had
and kind of the impact that
it's had not only on me but i think
people that have seen it wow
and so it had an impact on you and then
allowed you to
maybe fully heal from your experiences
as well i just think that art is healing
and and sometimes you can have your
experiences
play into your art and and how that
can really help one another and just to
be able to tell
this story and lend my my experiences
and and my
knowledge um i think was really
quite powerful now as someone in the
public eye
like you deal with how people perceive
you all the time be it based off of
what's being seen
what's here say we see a little bit of
that in the film as well
but as someone in the limelight how do
you handle it all
i'm a pretty open person when it comes
to
i mean i wrote a book that divulged a
lot of personal things about myself and
with social media i'm a very open book
as well and i
i'm a social person who likes to connect
with other people and i grew up in a
high school where i was a team therapist
and i know that connecting with other
people your age
is what can help heal you and realize
that you're not alone
and we're all craving that now more than
ever because there's something very you
know lonely about
where we've all been in our in our homes
not being able to see people that we
love
as much as we have been so i think that
owning your own story is just really
important and
to me the most important thing is that
the people that i
love and respect and that love me and
that i know
they know who i am they know what's true
they know that's like that's the
important thing you can't always
you can't live your life to write the
truths of
what you're hearing you know but um i
think because i am
a very open person that um
i i calling things out and kind of
saying wait a second
this is what's going on i can be real
[Music]
here